how many of you have used an electronic
spreadsheet like Microsoft Excel very
good now how many of you have run a
business with a spreadsheet by hand like
my dad did for his small printing
business in Philadelphia a lot less well
that's the way it was done for hundreds
of years in early 1978 I started working
on an idea that eventually became
VisiCalc and the next year it shipped
running on something new called an Apple
2 personal computer you could tell that
things had really changed when 6 years
later the Wall Street Journal ran an
editorial that assumed you knew would
visit calc was and maybe even we're
using it Steve Jobs back in 1990 said
that spreadsheets propelled the industry
forward VisiCalc propelled the success
of Apple more than any other single
event on a more personal note Steve say
there VisiCalc amend written for some
other computer you'd be interviewing
somebody else right now so physical was
was instrumental in getting personal
computers on business desks how did it
come about what was it what did I go
through to make it be what it was well I
first learned to program back in 1966
when I was 15 just a couple months after
this photo was taken
few high schoolers had access to
computers in those days but through luck
and an awful lot of perseverance I was
able to get computer time around the
city after sleeping in the mud at
Woodstock I went off to MIT to go to
college where to make money I worked on
the multix project our multix was a
trailblazing interactive time sharing
system have you heard of the Linux and
UNIX operating systems they came from
multix I worked on the multics versions
of what are known as interpreted
computer languages that are used by
people an on computer field
to do their calculations while seated at
a computer terminal after I graduated
from MIT I went to work for Digital
Equipment Corporation at Dec I worked on
software for the new area of
computerized typesetting I helped
newspapers replace their reporters
typewriters with computer terminals I'd
write software and then I go out in the
field to places like the Kansas City
Star where I would train users and get
feedback now this was real-world
experience that is quite different than
what I saw in the lab at MIT after that
I was project leader of the software for
Dex first word processor again a new
field like with typesetting the
important thing was crafting a user
interface that was both natural and
efficient for non computer people to use
after I was a deck I went to work for a
small company that made microprocessor
based electronic cash registers for the
fast food industry but I had always
wanted to start a company with my friend
Bob Franks and I met on the multix
project at MIT so I decided to go back
to school to learn as much as I could
about business and in the fall of 1977 I
entered the MBA program at Harvard
Business School I was one of the few
percentage of students who had a
background in computer programming
there's a picture of me from the
yearbook sitting in the front row now at
Harvard we learned by the case method we
do about three cases a day cases
consists of up to a few dozen pages
describing a particular business
situation they often have exhibits and
exhibits often have words and numbers
laid out in ways that make sense for the
particular situation they're usually all
somewhat different here's my homework
again numbers words laid out ways that
made sense lots of calculations we got
really close to our calculators in fact
here's my calculator for Halloween I
went dressed up as a calculator
at the beginning of each class the
professor would call on somebody to
present the case what they would do is
they would explain what was going on and
then dictate information that the
professor would transcribe on to the
many motorized blackboards at the front
of the class and then we'd have a
discussion one of the really frustrating
things is when you've done all your
homework you come in the next day only
to find out that you made an error in
all of the other numbers you did were
wrong and you couldn't participate as
well and we were marked by class
participation so sitting there with 87
other people in the class I got to
daydream a lot most programmers in those
days worked on mainframes building
things like inventory systems and
payroll systems and bill paying systems
but I had worked on interactive word
processing and on-demand personal
computation instead of thinking about
about paper printouts and punch cards I
imagined
a magic blackboard that if you erased
one number and wrote a new thing in all
of the other numbers would automatically
change like word processing with numbers
I imagined that my calculator had mouth
Hardware on the bottom of it and a
head-up display like in a fighter plane
and I could type some numbers in and
circle it and press the sum button and
right in the middle of a negotiation I'd
be able to get the answer now I just had
to take my fantasy and turn it into
reality my father taught me about
prototyping he showed me mock-ups that
he'd make to figure out the placement on
the page for the things for brochures
that he was printing and he'd use it to
get feedback from customers and OK's
before he sent the job off to the
presses the act of making a simple
working version of what you're trying to
build forces you to uncover key problems
and it lets you find solutions to those
problems much less expensively so I
decided to build a prototype I went and
went to a video terminal connected to
Harvard's time-sharing system and got to
work one of the first problems that I
ran into
who was how do you represent values and
formulas let me show you what I mean I
thought that you would point somewhere
type in some words then type in some
somewhere else putting some numbers and
some more numbers point where you want
the answer and then point to the first
press - point to the second and get the
result the problem was what should I put
in the formula it had to be something
the computer knew what to put in and if
you looked at the formula you needed to
know where on the screen it referred to
so the first thing I thought was the
programmer way of doing it the first
time you pointed to somewhere the
computer would ask you to type in a
unique name became pretty clear pretty
fast that that was going to be too
tedious the computer had to
automatically make up the name and put
it inside so I thought why not make it
be the order in which you create them I
tried that value one value to pretty
quickly I saw that if you had more than
a few values you'd never remember on the
screen things work then I said why not
instead of allowing you to put values
anywhere I'll restrict you to a grid
then when you point it to a cell the
computer could put the row and column in
as a name and if I did it like a map and
put ABC across the top and numbers along
the side if you saw a b7 in a formula
you'd know exactly where it was on the
screen and if you had a type of formula
in yourself you'd know what to do
restricting you to a grid helped solve
my problem it also opened up new
capabilities like the ability to have
ranges of cells but it wasn't too
restrictive you could still put any
value any formula in any cell and that's
the way we do it to this day almost 40
years later my friend Bob and I decided
that we were going to build this product
together I did more work figuring out
exactly how the program was supposed to
behave I wrote a reference card to act
as documentation it also helped me
ensure that the user interface I was
defining could be explained concisely
and clearly to regular people
Bob worked in the Attic of the apartment
that he rented in Arlington
Massachusetts this is the inside of the
attic Bob bought time on the MIT multics
system to write computer code on a
terminal like this and then he would
download test versions to a borrowed
Apple to over a phone line using an
acoustic coupler and then we would test
now for one of these tests I prepared
for this case about the Pepsi challenge
print wasn't working yet so I had a copy
everything down save wasn't working so
every time it crashed I had to type in
all the formulas again over and over
again the next day in class I raised my
hand I got called on and I presented the
case I did five-year projections I did
all sorts of different scenarios
I aced the case VisiCalc was already
useful the professor said how did you do
it well I don't want to tell him about
our secret program so so I said watch
this is not a diss imelda ploy by this
is subtracted that he said well want to
use a ratio a ratio that wouldn't have
been is exact what I didn't say was
divide isn't working yet eventually
though we did finish enough of VisiCalc
to be able to show it to the public
my dad printed up a sample reference
card that we could use as marketing
material in June of 1979 our publisher
and oust physik out to the world in a
small booth at the giant national
computer conference in New York City now
the New York Times had a humorous
article about the conference the
machines perform would seem religious
rights even as the believers gather the
painters in the Coliseum sign room are
adding to the Pantheon carefully
lettering visicalc and giant black on
yellow all held visicalc New York Times
all hail visicalc
that was the last mention of the
electronic spreadsheet in the popular
business press for about two years most
people didn't get it yet but some did in
October of 1979 we shipped VisiCalc it
came in a packaging that looked like
this and it looked like this running on
the Apple 2 and the rest as they say is
history
now there's an awful lot more to the
story but that'll have to wait for
another day one thing though Harvard
remembers
here's that classroom they put up a
plaque to commemorate what happened
there
[Music]
but but it also serves as a reminder
that you too should take your unique
backgrounds skills and needs and build
prototypes to discover and work out the
key problems and through that change the
world thank you
[Applause]